wie funktioniert der emissionshandel
während der europäischen union die luft
stark verschmutzt braucht co2
zertifikate eines erlaubnis eine
unternehmer eine tonne kohlendioxid
auszustoßen pro jahr braucht er mehrere
millionen zertifikate um den ausstoß von
kohlendioxid in der eu insgesamt zu
senken wird die anzahl an zertifikaten
reduzieren jedes jahr um rund zwei
prozent der unternehmer kann darauf nun
folgendermaßen reagieren er kann in
klimaschonende technik investieren um
seine emissionen ob das erlaubte maß zu
senken
oder er kauft zertifikate von einem
anderen unternehmen das bereits seine
emissionen gesenkt hat und nunmehr co2
zertifikate besitzt also selbst benötigt
[Musik]
überschüssige co2 zertifikate werden
geheim geht jedes unternehmen ist
berechtigt welche zu kaufen und zu
verkaufen
das ist die grundidee des
emissionshandels wird möglichst wenig
geld den klimaschutz zu verbessern
in der praxis allerdings besitzen die
unternehmen mehr zertifikate als sie
tatsächlich brauchen
es gibt seit jahren einen überschuss an
zertifikaten der den preis niedrig hält
[Musik]
in den klimaschutz zu investieren lohnt
sich für die unternehmen finanziell
deswegen kaum